este fin de semana india rompió el
récord de contagios diarios superando
las cifras registradas en septiembre del
año pasado el estado de maharashtra en
el occidente del país es una de las
regiones más golpeadas cuenta con más de
la mitad del total de casos que tiene
esa nación el estado ordenó cerrar todos
los bares restaurantes lugares de culto
y centros comerciales además de una
cuarentena total los fines de semana
las nuevas medidas entran en vigor este
lunes tenemos que tomarnos esto muy en
serio y ser extremadamente cuidadosos en
los casos de kobe de están aumentando
rápidamente tenemos que mantenernos a
salvo continuar con las medidas de
licenciamiento que ha tomado el gobierno
nacional
entre tanto el gobierno indio
intensificado su campaña de vacunación
en las últimas semanas pero el proceso
ha sido lento en una nación de más de
1300 millones de personas
todos deberían recordar lo rápido que
han aumentado los casos en el país y
vacunarse para salvar sus vidas hasta
que un día solo está por debajo de eeuu
y brasil
en número de casos con más de 12
millones registrados desde el inicio de
la pandemia